[Music]
hosted by film and theater director
orson wells who's out there is a 1975
nasa film that begins with the story of
wells famous 1938 radio adaptation of
the h.g wells novel the war of the
worlds a broadcast that panicked many
listeners who thought that martians were
invading the united states
the documentary then uses scientists
including carl sagan to explore views on
the possibility of extraterrestrial life
and ways to detect and communicate with
intelligent civilizations in the
universe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
before the cylinder fell
there was a general persuasion
that through all the deep of space
no life existed
beyond the petty surface
of our own
minute sphere
we know now
that in the early years of the 20th
century this world was being watched
closely
by
is
greater than mans
across an immense
ethereal gulf
minds that are to our minds as our minds
are to the beasts in the jungle
intellects
vast
cool
and unsympathetic
regarded this earth with envious eyes
and surely
drew their plans against us
hello
i'm orson welles
and i've been quoting from another wells
no relation
h.g wells the distinguished novelist
historian prophet who was also
the great master of science fiction
he wrote the war of the worlds on which
was based a certain
notorious radio broadcast which as some
of you may remember
said many thousands of our listeners
panicking into the streets all over the
country
hg denounced me for doing it but later
when he realized that our broadcast like
his story was not intended to
cause riots but just to entertain
we got to be good friends and i was
forgiven
whether all those people who jammed the
highways and even
took to the hills to escape the martians
have forgiven me
as another matter
this is it
we thought that this was it
listening to that show
i said we were very impressionable that
age because of buck rogers and flash
gordon
and
that really made a big impression on us
one fell in particular who owned a store
took the money from his cash register
and loaded his car up with food
and took off for the mountains and left
his wife and children at home
new york city was just demolished
and they were
coming closer
all of new north jersey is an inferno
and they are proceeding
south
i conceive can conceive of no nightmare
as terrifying
as establishing such communication
with the so-called superior or if you
wish advanced
technology
in outer space
george wald is a nobel prize-winning
biologist
one of a group of distinguished
scientists meeting on the subject of
extraterrestrial life
all of the people you will be seeing in
this program
scientists radio listeners
orson welles have one thing in common
each has had reason to believe in the
likely existence of non-earthly life in
the universe
i
think there's no question but that we
live in an inhabited universe
that has life all over it
what i'm imagining is
the facts that i've just stated becoming
generally known
so that uh
people know that out there is a million
other civilizations they all look
fabulously ugly and they're all a lot
smarter than us
that seems to me useful and a character
building experience for mankind
from the monstrous mars life of his
famous broadcast
orson welles will be taking us through
science fiction to science fact
to the new view of extraterrestrial life
now emerging from probes to the planets
interstellar discoveries and findings
about the nature of life itself
a real picture as astonishing in its way
as the science fiction of 1938
if there is
life out
there intelligent life
how did we ever get the notion that it
might be otherwise than friendly
well mars of course is the god of war so
the planet bearing his name might be
expected to have war-like intentions in
our broadcast the martians were as
aggressive and ruthless as any human
being
a ridiculous assumption on the face of
it they were supposedly as bad as we are
at our worst
and also much uglier they brandished
death rays and their slimy tentacles
and for a while at least just toward the
end of the radio play they appeared to
be totally invincible
what finally stopped them well here's
the way it went
in the words of the mythical professor
pierson of princeton who was our
commentator
i remember he said writing in his
journal when the whole
thing was put together again and the
world is in business
i remember
wandering through manhattan standing
alone on times square
and catching sight of a
lean dog
running down 7th avenue with a
piece of dark brown meat in its jaws
i walked up broadway
passed silent shop windows and suddenly
i caught sight of a martian machine
then across columbus circle
i could see standing in a silent row
19 of those great metal titans their
cowls empty their steel arms hanging
listlessly by their sides
i looked for the monsters that inhabit
those machines and then
before my eyes
i saw them stark
and silent
the martians themselves
were the flock of hungry birds
pecking and tearing brown shreds of
flesh from their dead bodies
later
when their bodies were examined in
laboratories it was found that
they had been killed by diseased
bacteria
against which their systems were
unprepared
slain
after all man's defenses had failed
by the humblest thing that god in his
wisdom had put upon this earth
the common cold
and that's the way it was
well quite a lot of things have happened
in the world since then
an invasion from the planet mars that at
least is one thing that
didn't happen
but in a way you know
we have been invading mars
if mars hasn't exactly been invaded well
it's certainly been investigated not
attacked but thoroughly
very thoroughly studied
observations of mars had begun long
before our broadcast
even back then in 1938 it seemed
plausible to many people
that life
could have developed on mars
just as it had on earth
peering through telescopes
scientists had seen
what
well
first a planet
that like our own earth
polar ice caps
[Applause]
[Music]
they were fascinated
to see that the ice caps
grew and receded with each year
large areas changed color with the
seasons
did that mean vegetation
straight lines were sighted on the
planet's surface
some called them canals
the american astronomer percival lowell
believed that these martian canals had
been created by an advanced
technological civilization
first in 1965 and then again in 1969
nasa sent spacecraft to fly by mars and
send back
scientific measurements
and close-up photographs
this is picture 21 a red picture wide
angle picture fantastic picture
that's beautiful that's beautiful look
at those little craters
this is a narrow angle camera view
the mariner missions were great
achievements for the scientists
but the pictures of bars
showed a world of total desolation
was mars less like the earth then and
more like the moon
there were no canals no cities no areas
of cultivation no signs of upheaval or
layering in the martian crust to
indicate that the planet was active or
evolving geologically
the pictures revealed no volcanoes to
spew out gases that could enrich the
atmosphere
and water
so essential to life
seem to be present only in traces the
atmosphere was so thin
as to make the possibility of life
seem even more remote
for the fans of science fiction
not very exciting
but for scientists
the whole excitement is finding out the
facts
that's the whole name of the game
now these first flybys had revealed only
some of the facts
but all the same the exploration of mars
and of all the other planets of the
solar system
was actually getting underway
i can't
i can't feel that any person with any
soul
can look out on that universe that
surrounds us
and can
imagine the immensity of it and the
history of it
without being rather impressed with the
idea that we as little atoms made of the
same stuff those stars are made of have
the capability to regard
the other part of the universe one piece
of the universe has the ability to look
at another part of the universe and
wonder about it that's a very amazing
thing and it brings into one's mind all
kinds of thoughts about
religion and philosophy and so on
but don't ask me about life on mars okay
in the fictional
martian story in the war of the worlds
it was understood that the martians were
fighting for their own survival
their planet was growing so cold and
inhospitable that they might perish if
they remained
well real life confined to such a planet
would fight for survival by trying to
change itself
by evolving
every living thing on earth has evolved
from the lowly
the invisibly small
microbe
given nourishment the microbe will grow
colonies so vast
that they rapidly become visible to the
eye here on our planet
microbes have adapted to survive the
most hostile conditions
arid deserts the frozen himalayas
in trenches under thousands of tons of
pressure
in the ocean deeps
biologists at ames laboratory are
discovering adaptive capabilities in
life forms that a few years ago would
have been regarded as fantastic
within the cooling systems of atomic
reactors
organisms have been discovered
flourishing
where radiation could be expected to
destroy any living thing
in hospitals that use ultraviolet for
sterilization
strains have been found resistant to the
killing radiation
biologists are growing organisms
in salt solutions
in acids in alkalines in ammonia gas in
boiling hot springs
in ice that is thawed for part of every
day
in the vacuum of a space simulator
life forms
have been flourishing for years
without oxygen
[Music]
scientists
are studying the kinds of environments
that could challenge life forms on the
planets and moons of the solar system
in 1971
mariner 9 arrived at mars equipped to go
into orbit and stay for a while a good
thing too
because when it arrived my surface was
obscured by a global dust storm
as the storm abated a whole new mars
began to make its appearance
the first feature that swam into view
poking up through the dust
appeared to be a huge impact crater
but it stood miles above the martian
lowlands on the peak of an immense
mountain
next olympica
and as the dust settled further the
stunning truth emerged
that the mountain on mars was indeed
a gigantic volcano
so geologically
mars was not a dead planet after all
vast stretch marks on the planet showed
that my surface is shifting and changing
on a colossal scale
mars is beginning to look geologically
at least
more like the earth
and less like the moon
and then new evidence of water has begun
to turn up in surprising ways
among the many clouds in the martian
atmosphere
some have been found to be composed of
water
then close-ups of the surface have begun
to turn up strange sinuous patterns some
compare with the patterns cut into the
surface of our own planet
by the mississippi river slowly the
interpretation emerged
that only a fluid
flowing continuously over the martian
surface
could have caused such patterns of
erosion
some scientists didn't agree but
astronomer carl sagan theorized that
mars indeed contained a great deal more
water than we'd supposed
the water might remain locked within its
crust as permafrost during ice age time
such as the present but during cycles of
warmth when the polar caps release gases
to form a heavier atmosphere the water
may be released into clouds such clouds
could bathe the planet in reigns
for thousands
and perhaps millions of years
if sagan's interpretation is correct
life could have originated on mars
in favorable cycles
and may have adapted itself to harsher
conditions as they developed
and indeed
may exist on mars
to this day
exobiologists are studying other
environments
even as they prepare to search directly
for life
beyond the planet earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
flying by jupiter
pioneer 10
confirmed estimates that within its
atmosphere are combinations of gases
similar to those in which life
originated on earth
while a second pioneer is being aimed to
curve past jupiter and fly by saturn
earth-based measurements show that a
moon of saturn
nearly the size of the planet mercury
contains an atmosphere
water
and surprising warmth
a viking spacecraft is being readied
to land on mars in 1976
carrying an automated chemical
laboratory to sample martian soil for
life forms
the discovery of just one bacteria on
mars
or any other body of the solar system
would indicate that the whole chain of
evolutions
cosmic chemical and biological
is at work everywhere
in that case
the creation of life anywhere in the
universe
would be more the rule
than the exception
in that case
there may be other intelligent
civilizations
capable of communicating with us
the impact on ourselves of contact with
another intelligent civilization
how it might come about and what the
effects might be
is now being discussed by serious
thinkers the world over
this symposium at boston university
includes astronomer carl sagan
anthropologist ashley montagu
christa stendel is dean of the harvard
school of divinity professor berenson
teaches a course titled
search for life in the universe
professor philip morrison of mit
co-authored the first seriously recent
paper on possible modes of communication
with extraterrestrial life george wald
won the nobel prize in 1971 for his work
in physiology
it is now okay to talk about life
elsewhere or intelligent artifacts
a decade or two ago it wasn't okay
it was considered
too speculative to be worth any
investment of time
it's that the number of stars in our
galaxy alone is so staggeringly large in
the order of 10 11 or more
the probability of stars having
planetary systems is so high we think
perhaps half
the probability that those planetary
systems might be comparable with our own
and that the stars have some kind of an
echo sphere a sphere in which the
radiation is suitable for life that it's
not too hot not too cold meeting the
other criteria seems so reasonable
these bits of information come from
astronomy primarily
then we join with the biochemists who
tell us about the probable evolution of
life here on earth the kinds of elements
that are necessary for it dna molecules
amino acids and the like amino acids
which have now been found in meteorites
that
we have now found interstellar molecules
floating out in the space between stars
so that you know the materials for a
carbon-based life exists we know that
many of the building blocks of life in
our own solar system exist off of our
planet
if you put these kinds of probabilities
together it begins to lead to sorts of
conclusions that we started with as an
initial premise
and which apparently no one on the panel
has disagreed and that is that life must
exist in the universe and it must exist
quite abundantly
the most optimistic estimates in the
view of many about the number of
civilizations that there might be in the
galaxy
is of the order of vermilion
which means that only one in a few
hundred thousand stars
has such civilizations and that would
mean a billion such places
just in our own galaxy
that might contain life
as i believe there's a society of these
groups not just one they're probably
very many there's only one we have no
hope of finding him there are probably
thousands
maybe as many as a million they probably
already have had a long history of this
same experience of finding new ones and
bringing them into the network
and i would imagine an advanced
civilization wanted to talk to us they
would say oh look those guys must be
extremely backwards uh go into some
ancient museum and pull out one of those
what are they called radio telescopes
and
steam without them in 1970 i study the
feasibility for picking up interstellar
communication was made in california
by a number of radio scientists there as
well as astronomers and others it's
called project cyclops
the outcome of that study was that the
united states had the technical
capability of building a large radio
array which would be able to scan the
heavens
with fairly great resolution and and
power sensitivity out to a distance of
many hundreds or possibly thousands of
light years
with the very distinct possibility of
picking up a signal if it were there
our present technology is able to detect
ourselves
anywhere in this galaxy of about 250
billion stars
first the people beaming the message
will be incredibly alien
even if their biochemistry resembles a
biochemist professor wall teaches it
will not be all that close you know
uh it will have enzymes but it will be
the lr the ld situation will be quite
different and i don't know what chains
of enzyme systems they will have at all
and you couldn't eat their food very
likely even though the same biochemistry
anymore we eat the food of a mushroom
it's very difficult
but the
so i think first of all
there will be two great phases of this
eventual time which i think will come in
10 years or 100 years or i don't know
maybe longer
when some
satisfactory radio telescope work or
something similar will acquire evidence
of the
deliberate beaming of a message
protracted message out into space
so i think that will be easy and of
course extraordinarily important you
will know very little of what that
message says say that it exists and
maybe some general geographic
information from how far away it's
coming
what kind of a star where
and then i think that you will
have pouring into the recorders pouring
into the recorders
week after week month after month decade
after decade an enormous body of
obviously interesting and meaningful
pulses
and you'll be able to read them
slowly and fitly because they will not
be coded but they'll be anti-coded
that's to say the people who designed
them the beings who designed them will
have thought very carefully how to make
the maximum number of mathematical clues
the best way to single out the meaning
will be made available
i think the most important thing that it
will bring to us
if we can finally understand it will be
a description if it exists at all
of how
beings
disposing of great technology were able
to fashion a world in which they could
live and
persevere and maintain something of
worth and beauty for a long period of
time and finally it would end our social
and cultural isolation
to date we have been bounded not only
into our own countries and into our own
small regions on this planet but most
assuredly within our solar system itself
if there are the tens of billions of
other civilizations which the
predictions indicate might be then we
would join a larger galactic community
in 1976
we're going to be able to explore mars
for perhaps not so humble
microorganisms
before and after that
we'll be searching the planets
and the galaxies
for clues to fill in the new patterns
we're discovering
the evolution
of evolutions
that has produced us
and the possible millions of other
civilizations
it is conceivable that a spherical ship
will land in front of the washington
monument and a figure with four antennas
and otherwise looking like the
professional football player will walk
out
and demand to see our leader
but i i hope
very much that the the universe of
circumstances wider than the rather
shoddy imaginations of science fiction
writers for 30 or 40 years and i'm
pretty convinced it is we've not found
their guidance so great in any but the
most modest activities like going to the
moon which is not very much
the difference between the spacecrafts
of nasa
and the lurid flying sorcery of that old
radio war of the worlds is the
difference between science and science
fiction and yes between war and peace
it's our own world which is turned out
to be the interplanetary visitor we're
the ones who were moving
out there
not with death rays but with cameras
not to conquer but
simply to learn
we are in fact behaving ourselves far
better
out there
than we ever have back here at home
on our own planet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1997 the u.s air force published
reports on the so-called roswell
incident in 1947 in the